yeah and he's
um
you know he's basically he's been there
for 50 years so he's like Jay Edgar
Hoover and the only way that you last in
that Agency for 50 years is by
carrying water for the pharmaceutical
industry and under his watch He's
supposed to prevent autoimmune and
allergic diseases
under his watch chronic disease has gone
from affecting 12 percent of the
American population to 54 percent we
take more pharmaceutical drugs than
anybody in the world highest prices are
we it's we he's made this country
pharmaceutical Nation yeah my brother's
allergic to Sesame seeds but you know
exactly and the way that you can
allergies is from the aluminum action in
the vaccine which is meant is put in
that vaccine
to initiate an allergic response and it
and so if you have sesame seed oil is an
excipient in the vaccine or if you're if
you're eating sesame seeds when you have
that aluminum adjuvant in you
it can promote provoke an allergic a
permanent analogy
and if you look you don't know why
anybody who is my age who has food
allergies very very hard to find I think
it's one in something like 1300 and
today if you're born again after he'll
have a football team yeah everybody
after 1989. so any anybody who was born
after 89 I think it's one in 12 now oh
it just went from one in ten thousand in
my generation to one in every 34 kids
and it's the same with all these chronic
diseases that are all listed as side
effects the modern vaccine was
completely developed by Tony fauci
he hands it to a private group they then
they put two billion dollars of federal
money into allowing them to develop it
and then Tony fauci's agency keeps half
the profits from the vaccine
oh it would be like you know I've
certainly EPA many times for being a
capture to agency but you know what
would what would it be like if EPA made
half of its profits selling coal yeah
it's the same thing these agencies are
not independent agencies they're
completely captured and
you have and you know the all of the
other institutions of government that
that should stand between a greedy
Corporation and a vulnerable child
having compromised
Congressman Congress gets more money
lobbying money from the from the
pharmaceutical industry than any other
industry they give them double what oil
and gas I'm talking about lobbyists
there's more Pharma lobbyists on Capitol
Hill than there are Congressman senators
and Supreme Court Justices combined
Regulatory Agencies have been captured
the Press
is utterly captured and that's because
in 1997 we passed a law in this country
or FDA you know changed regulation to
make it legal for the first time for
um television and radio and newspapers
the advertised pharmaceutical products
on the air direct to Consumer Farms when
was that what year was that I was 97. I
said oh there's only two countries in
the world that allow that everybody
agrees a terrible thing to do oh and
it's half of our commercials now as well
well Roger Ailes who founded Fox told me
that that there are 22 commercials on
his average Evening News show and 17 of
those are pharmaceutical oh yeah I'm
just trying to get through half a Family
Guy next thing you know I have HIV by
the end of the day so you know what I'm
saying it's just like the fear it's in a
lot of it's fear too and they give you
pictures of like oh here's a happy
family but you might have this looming
in the distance you know yeah you might
have said that he wanted to do one of
those ads where you know they you know
they list all these horrible things from
the side effects and the people are
walking around happy and laughing and
playing football
he said he just wants to do one of those
ads where people are actually acting out
the side effects
the idea that we can trust an expert to
tell us what's good for us
every trial I've ever been involved with
there's an expert on both sides and
they're both equally convincing and
that's why you need the debate yeah
that's why you know saying Tony fauci
that's why people say I want a second
opinion yeah he's a doctor he hasn't
treated patients for 50 years
he's a doctor but he doesn't know
anything about economics
he cannot tell you how many people are
dying of of
um of unemployment
or studies from the 1980s there's a
famous study in 1982 in the 1980s there
was these huge downsizing and layoffs
that were occurring in our country
and there was a whole cottage industry a
whole school of Economics that grew up
to see what happens to people when they
get unemployed
and there's one very famous study it's
it's cited hundreds of times in the
literature that said that for every
additional one point in unemployment
there's 37 000 Americans die yeah nine
nine thousand I have heart attacks 900
from the suicide and so on and so on
hypertension diabetes
all of these bad things there's a
Cascade of bad things happen
our population was about half so you
have to double that
and say for every point in unemployment
we're gonna lose maybe 60 000 dead
and otherwise would not have died
and are we start saving more lives are
we killing more people with the
quarantine and we are killing with coven
that's a great question nobody has done
that assessment and that's the weird
thing is people say listen to The
Experts
and Anthony fauci is on an expert on
deaths from unemployment
and you know and when when Britain did
this study
written's at in five weeks in April and
May
with 30 000 excess deaths
and elderly facilities which they call
nursing homes in Britain but only ten
thousand of them had covered twenty
thousand of them died from isolation oh
yeah I'm not shocked I mean I noticed
even just in my own like you know going
a 12-step and going to recovery and not
being able to have those meetings and
not being able to oh I mean the
addiction rates are I cannot even
imagine bro right I cannot even imagine
how like and you and I know people
yeah it's hard out and died yeah you
know during this or people who couldn't
go to our meetings you know and it's a
lot of people's Lively and that and
that's a lot of people and there's no
talk like there's just no talk about the
human effect of some of this it feels
like sometimes it's just about this
weird medical effect
um or medical fear which kind of it's
not shocking then if big if if big
Pharma and that money is is so slowly
seeped its arms all the way in
everything that at the very Pinnacle of
discussion the only thing people are
concerned about the media is concerned
about is the medical effects of it and
no longer the human effects of it I mean
it's almost Henderson Cooper
ever not once had an economist on to say
[ __ ] bro I don't know bro
[Laughter]
you know I mean that's just my thought
bro but you know what I'm saying I'll
put side control on that dude in a
heartbeat but that's just me you know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one